right how do you see behavior change
between what I think many would consider
the great investors from everyone else
is there a change or is it they've
basically done the prep work to prevent
themselves from making mistakes during
those those weak moments so well Sir
John Templeton was famous for when
stocks were doing very poorly he would
make a list of his favorite stocks and
put buy orders in at prices way below
where they were and his reasoning was if
the stocks ever got to that level he
would not have the guts to put the order
in
he just couldn't do it so there was a
guy who understood his own human nature
I love that what we do is we are
entirely rules based I never override I
mean you know people would say to me
well you know is it the formulas is it
no it's not the formulas you know if
you've got the best idea in the world
you can scream it from the rooftops and
people either won't believe you well you
know hear you and certainly even if they
attempt to do it won't do it right yep
and so we're not worried about that what
we worry about is look we're we're
constantly improving our algorithms that
select models and portfolios and I've
got a great research team that's what we
spend all of our time on but the thing
that I think I am proudest of is the
fact that in my 30-plus year career
history as an investor I have never
emotionally given in mmm-hmm by
overwriting a model by overriding a
model yep
and we had and that's hard you know and
just just to clarify so people who
teaches us what you're talking about
there is you have a model that is just
you know based on data right or in
formulas that you've created that tell
you when to buy when to sell when to
hold right basically precisely they give
you direction they give us directions
and you can either listen or not yeah
right we we used to we used to have a
context or a contest back at
O'Shaughnessy capital
where we would put the list of 50 names
that were being selected by our small
cap growth strategy and we would have
everyone guess which we're gonna be the
ten big performers in which we're gonna
be the ten worst performers well you can
see this coming a mile away everyone
that they thought were gonna be the 10
worst ended up being for the most part
the 10 best and the 10 best ended up
being the 10 worst and so I just you
know I basically made my mind up after a
trade that I actually wrote about when I
sold a huge position of putt puts right
literally on the Friday before the
Monday stock market crash Tahoe and I
did that which I'll send you a link to I
did that because I was watching TV and I
was listening to the radio and everyone
was like oh this is so overdone we're
gonna have the biggest bounce panic
rally ever and I let my emotions
determine what I was doing and I was
sold all the puts and then Monday
happened and so I thought of it I used
to keep it you had a bad Monday but for
other reasons yes but but I I also
recommend people keep journals so that
you remember what you actually were
thinking in real time because again the
brain will play beautiful tricks on you
it will make you think that you were not
thinking that way at all then you go
back and there it is in your own
handwriting staring at you in the face
and you go oh god I was thinking that